I started chess as a 12 year old which
is quite late I probably saw this game
when I was 13 or there is about and it
made a very forceful strong impression
that kappa blanka was impervious he he
as challenger to the aging Emanuel
Lasker who there had been Wilhelm
steinitz who had beaten Blackburn and
steinitz had defended his match title he
had lost to a Emmanuel Lasker and Lasker
was seeking new challengers and kappa
blanka was a up rising star and they
kappa blanka
had gotten the government of cuba to
sponsor the match to a very large prize
fund so much so that emmanuel Lasker
accepted the challenge this single game
really had a powerful outcome on the
whole match itself the final score was
four games to nil many games were drawn
Lasker wood drew from the match citing
exhaustion from the Havana heat be that
as it may it just seemed that kappa
blanka was in complete control and again
this game was a very powerful indicator
of the strength of kappa blanka but
Lasker gets somehow short-shifted like
he lost the match he didn't win any
games kappa blanka was clearly his
superior and so we think kappa blanka
was much stronger than manuel Alaska a
lot of people don't realize that in
later games after this World
Championship match
Alaska won some games begins kappa
blanka i mean he was still
quite a force quite a force to be
reckoned with
so in those days is like the Queens
gambit declined was was considered
correct play if you did something like a
king's indiana groom felled or gosh
knows even a modern Benoni you were like
treated like you know some barbarian who
didn't have culture and understanding
and it was blacks job to equalize out of
the opening not to go for crazy gambits
or something like that Bishop g5 all
very standard play Bishop e7 Knight c3
and now what was very interesting is Kam
annual Lasker is very well known for the
Lasker defense to the Queens gambit
declined which usually includes the move
h6 Bishop drops back to h4 and the
so-called freeing maneuver 94 the idea
is that after a couple of trades takes
takes rook c1 trade trade c7 c6 black
then castles and oftentimes he takes on
c4 and he breaks with E 5 so this
variation got its name from Emanuel
Lasker he introduced it into practice it
bears his name and for those of you who
may recall the match between Veselin
Topalov and this wanna thon Anand
played in Sophie a few years ago in the
12th and final game this she played the
black side
velasca defense and won the decisive
contest to win the world championship
title and World Championship match in
Sofia Bulgaria so intriguingly Lasker
didn't choose his favorite defense
instead he went for castles
and now rook c1 and now in this position
the freeing maneuver simply does not
work if you try to play h6 Bishop h4
Knight e4 you run into a problem takes
takes takes now thanks to the rook on c1
it ends up capturing the pawn on c7 okay
so no longer can you play 94 i I
strongly strongly recommend however the
inclusion of the move h7 h6 is black I
always like to have to have lift in the
position so to speak in those days
lasker play to move b7 b6 which today we
might say hey that's a dubious move
that's not the move you're supposed to
do in those days virtually everybody
exclusively played the move c6 Bishop d3
takes on c4 takes and this move the so
called Alekhine Alexander Alekhine
freeing maneuver because the knight on
d5 protects the square f4 is not
considered wise to play the move Bishop
f4 had you included the move h6 Bishop
h4 then white can just play bishop g3
and the effect of the freeing maneuver
would have no effect so after Bishop
takes c7 Queen takes c7 castles we get
the same freeing maneuver as Lasker's
variation we get a very very similar
outcome one key difference is that this
pawn is not on h6 which i think is very
useful for black to have okay
so if you're not going to include the
move h6 it's because you want to play
the move c6 and trade pieces like this
so Laska if you read these old books
about the world championship match well
Lasker's move gets a question mark and
kappa blanka gets extolled for his
magnificent mastery and understanding of
the opening and that quote
kappa blanka refutes Lasker's
preparation over the board okay which i
find hilarious
in hindsight so C takes d5 e takes d5
Queen a4 and again universally you'll
discover that it is written that this
move puts overwhelming pressure on
blacks position and your threat for
white is to play Queen c6 with double
attacks and everything and if black
plays the move Bishop b7 well then you
get to play Bishop a6 and white gets a
lot of a play on the Queen side that
this is that the experts would consider
that this position after Knight e5 is
very favorable for the first player okay
so Lasker however played the move c5
and he and said in a sense returns the
ball to kappa blanka and says hey with
c5 what do you got
you're certainly as white not taking
this pawn because that would be a
terrible reaction in combination with
the move Queen a for the night will
attack the queen force it to go back and
black will be very happy having played
the move Queen a4 again it makes less
sense to play the move Bishop a six now
because white would be attacking a piece
that hasn't even developed like would
very happily trade pieces and probably
offer an exchange of Queens and black
would have nothing to worry about
because he's his moves of all looking to
the center he's put all of his pieces in
the center of the board okay so
essentially kappa blanka has no choice
but to follow up with his on his
previous move with queen c6 if he
doesn't play the move Queen c6 then why
did you play the move Queen a4 yeah okay
so Queen c6 attacking the rook in the
corner rook b8 now again you don't have
time to play a move like Bishop f4
attacking the rook because black is
perfectly happy and ready to play Bishop
d7 kicking the Queen out and gaining
time White has no choice but he has to
capture this pawn and again and again if
you read all of these books you'll read
how kappa blanka refuted Emmanuel askers
pawn sacrifice and it became the model
of play but in reality this is really
dangerous stuff for white because first
of all if this guy is still in the
center of the board these guys haven't
moved
and you know you're you're spending a
lot of time to essentially win one pawn
black will get good development and good
compensation so here's a very critical
moment here I don't like the move that
Emmanuel Lasker played he played the
move Bishop d7 which is a very natural
move it's by no means bad don't get me
wrong it's by no means bad I just think
that he should have played Knight takes
d5 Queen takes d5 Bishop d7 in this
moment Bishop takes Queen takes Queen g5
where else are you going to move your
queen if you allow black to simply end
up capturing this Knight and capturing
this pawn Black has better development
look at White's pieces still on the
first rank basically this move is forced
Queen takes Knight takes pawn takes look
at the development look at the
development rip d1 basically a forced
move I don't see any better move if you
take the pawn well there's a check to
begin with and all you've got is an
extra pawn in the middle of the board
that may be a weakness Knight f6 rook
takes d4 rook c8 check this out this is
a very good Bishop you move your bishop
I'll take your part this is a very good
rook on the open file the best I can
find for white is the move f3 to harness
the power of the Bishop h6 kicking the
knight back check
you got a drop back with the rook rooks
c2 now you're threatening to take the
pawn
you're not even material down
rook d2 and a draw by repetition so
blacks entire strategy is completely
sound that is to say all of these books
that were written that you know Jose
Raul kappa blanka refuted black's
opening gambit are just wrong if
anything
and even the way the game went
kappa pardon me Alaska had great play
for the pawn after the move Bishop b7
but again had Lasker just played the
very direct groups let me get the right
move as shown now this is all very
forcing all a very very forcing line I
can't avoid this line of play for black
ever white and I just think that he
would have made a very comfortable drop
oh wow
alright but even as the game went on
you'll see the kappa blanka have
enormous problems converting so here
White's a pot up of course but now
something has taken shape in the
position that's a little bit more
awkward than the pawn itself and that is
this pin this pin is a really an
annoying pin and it really contains
blacks resources that this knight on f6
can't jump to e4 can't jump to d5 rook
c8 naturally preparing operations along
the c-file Queen a3 a very very good
move probably I would I would go so far
as to suggest that Lasker had this
position at home that Alaska had this
position at home had expected all the
of these moves and I'd missed the real
strength of the move Queen a3 perhaps
Lasker was dreaming that white would
really get too greedy and went upon but
as we would quickly see black is clearly
for choice black got this wonderful
c-file action there's queen bee four
checks White's King has a target this
would be in fact a disaster for white
but this move Queen a3 really freezes a
black for a moment he wants to get out
of this pin but if he does something
banal like Queen e6 well you're just
inviting the ship c4 so the game went
Queen e6 pardon me he did play queen e6
sorry
Bishop takes f6 Knight takes f6 Bishop
a6 this was really a good move and it
was almost like the hallmark of Kappa
Blancas play was this wonderful
simplicity today we may hate his you
know we extol kappa blanka on the one
hand but then when we get to watch games
of the top grandmasters in the world
today we want to see action we want to
see blood we don't want to see just
simplifying positions but this is really
a great move by kappa blanka and again
the hallmark of his career was his
taking a simple approach to complex
positions so at the moment we can see
that White's upon up but he faces real
issues first of all this takes on the
c-file discovering an attack against the
rook this takes on f3 twice you know
this problems if black ever gets to take
take and take this pawn on d4 you're
really going to hate White's position so
Bishop a6 in a sense is box meaning
force move or only move but also good
move okay
so again a lot of the books I read when
I was a kid about this match was this
idea that you know kappa blanka really
dominated and it was really this game to
that I mean really changed the match and
really I think strongly and more so than
it should have impacted Emanuel Lasker
because he had come with this newfangled
idea sacrificing a pawn had made these
great preparations and got this position
where even though he's a pawn down in
Kappa Blancas doing his thing he still
has real opportunity as well
he played Bishop takes f3 the best
chance the in fact the only move if you
play in this position C takes d4 which
looks really good rook takes c8 rook
takes c8 castles bishop oh sorry bishop
I want to say Bishop takes f3 Bishop
takes c8 you really want to play this
move Queen g5 checkmate Queen here it
doesn't work not only because I have
pawn takes new variation but I have even
a cruncher a much more you don't have
time to play Queen h3 and Queen G to
mate
I simply play Queen e7 if you go Queen
h3 check oh so close and yet so far
so Bishop you want to take on d4 take
take castles Bishop takes Queen takes
rook here now this is a kappa blanka
position if there's ever one White's
just a super safe pawn to the good okay
this is like almost certain death for
anybody in the world it's just a very
bad position
or black so Kappa pardon me Alaska
played in this position after Bishop a6
Bishop takes f3 Bishop takes c8 rook
takes c8 takes takes now Lasker's an
exchange down but the position is still
very very difficult for white it's not
easy to neutralize Black's play black
played rook g1 essentially there's a
weakness in the position the King is
still in the center heaven forbid you
should ever be in a situation where
you've actually traded the c5 pawn for
the e3 pawn because White's King would
be exposed and you're only in exchange
up and for the moment this guy and this
guy are not really in the game so here
it's like everybody just acted as if
it's lost or like like this was like
kappa blanka wonderfully trading down
the position to a stone-cold win or
something like that the lot of the
authors were writing with the aid of the
result of the game as opposed to seeing
how really difficult Kappa Blancas task
was rook e8 a very nasty move there's no
Queen takes a 7 business anymore rook
takes III I got a perpetual check at
least
okay so Queen got back into the game g7
g6 just everything's fine King comes to
f1 rook efore sweep okay
please take this pawn and bring my
knight into the game or take this pawn
and let my knight come here and possibly
here to g4 this is by no means easy to
convert Queen d1 that Queen on f3 is
just in the position very very powerful
Queen h3
Shak rook g2 and now a crucial moment a
crucial question in the game Knight f6
was played and I think that that's a
fine move there's nothing wrong with
Knight f6 but there's also something to
be said for C takes d4 eat akes d4 and
now Knight f6 there's some problems I
mean there is some real real problems
rook g4 is a principal threat in the
position for black I think that Lasker
didn't want he wanted to keep the pawn
on e3 not to allow a rook coming across
to c3 but even after rook c3 Queen h4
there's still a lot of work this pawn on
d4 is weak so it was a key moment a
crucial decision I think the move Knight
f6 was certainly okay
but also the move c5 takes d4 was it was
a crucial okay
King g1 in order to sidestep the threat
of rook g4 takes and this was the move
that kappa blanka played the difference
between capturing the Putin move the
pawn one move early is that Kappa had
this move rook c4 the difference is now
if you take the pawn I think what was it
I think it was rook g4 that the players
didn't like what was it something like
this hold on I know that that there was
a good reason he didn't recapture hold
on hold on what was that good reason it
might have been simply the mundane
Knight d5 stopping rook c3 as well
as intimating that you want to play
Knight f4 92 again we can see that
blacks pieces are definitely very very
active so kappa blanka being kappa
blanka he plays rook c4 in order to
reduce blacks attacking chances takes
tags tags now we've got a pawn for the
exchange but again look at the pieces
does this look like an easy win to
anybody
oh no check check
takes okay so now again everybody and
his brother is just basically now now
he's got him now everything is secure
you're going to play rook F - it's an
immortal pin you know White's winning
not true not true this is still a very
very hard position for kappa blanka to
win Queen e6 rook F - okay now it's very
likely that the move Queen g4 check
Queen takes d4 Knight takes G for rook
c2 is in fact a very easy win because
the knight cannot handle the rook and
these the weaknesses on the Queen side
but what's very interesting is after the
move g5 h for I stuck this in micah and
my engine today and was really having a
good time looking at this position my
engine in the game kappa Laster took
this pawn okay a move I didn't like I
was really wondering what my engine
would say sorry let's just do that again
I've got it all printed out h6 so my
engine says h4 and then it just jumps
like - like -
when it sees the move h5 okay jumps up
explains to me that queen g4 queen g4
rook
Knight g4 rook F 2 followed by rook a 7
wins in this position it starts to
evaluate as to and then it comes down to
one point eight thinks things things
things things and eventually it sinks to
nine tenths of a pawn and the way it
plays for white is as follows so all I'm
doing is I'm just keeping I'm stick I've
agreed to stay in the immortal pin my
computer in this position we'll go cook
f5 and claim to be better it doesn't see
a way of breaking black's fortress but
it claims that it's a much better
position for white but it could not beat
me I just kept the position they try to
move maneuver its King to different
things to avoid the 50 move rule but
it's normally speaking whenever I see an
immortal pin like this I've struck by
how often the superior side is and that
the superior sight almost always wins
these immortal pins that you're in but
in this particular case I just don't see
how kappa blanka would have broken black
it's not easy at all and well I didn't
find it anyway that unfortunately I
think Lasker had the same problem that
we all have is instinctively he wanted
to get out of the immortal pin and that
was why he took this pawn then it's kind
of ugly right now we start to see some
ugliness there's too many weaknesses and
we can understand however having said
that Lasker says okay I am an exchange
down
but let me do my best to make it as
difficult for you as possible Knight g4
Queen g5 check King back rook f5 ok so
now the problem with Queen takes III
pardon me I think that was played no he
first played h5 just second Queen takes
III Queen takes c3 Knight takes c3 rook
here night here rookie to again this is
a very unpleasant ending for black even
though he has two pawns for the exchange
the fact that his King is cut away from
his pawns on the Queen side white is
quickly playing rooks e2 and rushing to
win one of blacks pawns it's a it's a
much better position for white and
possibly simply winning ending hence we
see the move h5 by Manuel Alaska okay
even when you're losing you have to make
your opponent work you have to make it
as difficult as possible and to create
as many problems for your opponent as
you possibly can h5 check King check
check this is probably simply for the
time control and we see this repetition
okay b3 okay what move are we on now
this is move 39 Queen d6 again you know
look at this we've got ideas you know
Queen h2 check Queen f4 check Queen back
to f1 it like this endgame of you know
like again you can win two pawns for the
exchange
but this endgame is often it's repeat
itself it comes up so
often this ending Queen to d7 to defend
the f7 pawn takes Knight takes III and
again we really have the strong
impression okay white should be winning
now I mean he's got a rook versus Knight
there's a pawn on f7 sure but look
White's Queen and rook are going to
dominate not so true okay
Queen f3 Queen d4 Queen a a Czech King
here Queen b7 check and this is
literally the deciding loot the time
trouble blunder the less control here
Lasker played the blunder Queen f8 and
simply resigned after Queen b8 the crazy
part is this position King d6 I put this
in my engine and my engine said plus 10
10 100s of a pawn it says no way blacks
got really good play with this Queen at
night and we all know that the Queen and
knight in combination make a very
formidable attacking units especially
when has no cover at all for whites King
and it would have been fascinating to
see how the game might have gone from
here would kappa blanka have made a
perpetual check
would he have tried to play for the win
recognizing that it the match is just
getting started again this is game 2 had
Lasker saved this game as what I'm
saying the whole outcome of the match
might have been different he wouldn't
have lost his confidence about his
opening preparation and
it would have been a great great really
just a different match and again I just
want to go back really fast to this
moment where you played Queen a4 even
today amongst top grandmasters this
position is considered better for white
because the echoes of 1921 and but if
what I say is true that Alaska was just
fine in this position then the whole
concept of b6 and c5 by Emanuel Lasker
is as valid today as it would have been
in 1921 any questions I did good yeah
all right well thank you all for coming
it was very nice